have you ever seen a movie from the
2000s and thought to yourself wow times
sure have changed well these are 10 of
those movies that you wouldn't see made
nowadays there is so much in Tropic
Thunder that wouldn't be okay today the
movie is sort of a parody of the movie
industry making fun of the way that
they'd cast white actors to play people
of color so they cast Robert Downey Jr
and put him in blackface while giving
him lines that sounded a bit
stereotypical what do you mean you
people and we haven't even gotten to Ben
Stiller whose character had previously
played a mentally challenged boy named
Simple Jack there's even a scene where
Robert warns Ben never to go full r word
because it would hurt his chances of
winning an Oscar when asked if a movie
like Tropic Thunder could be made
nowadays Robert said oh you could do it
but even he'd admit it was impossible to
not have it be an offensive nightmare of
a movie at least Tropic Thunder was
somewhat self-aware unlike our next
entry on this list Julie may have set
brennifer on track to be married 20
years later but that doesn't mean it
wasn't any good the plot centers around
the two of them kidnapping a mentally
challenged man played by an abled actor
and Ben isn't entirely kind to him eat
your food stupid but it gets worse
Jennifer's character is introduced as a
lesbian who switches teams because she
just hasn't seen a man like Ben before
and that isn't even to mention just how
poorly written the movie is it's time
huh
the movie apparently even got Ben in
trouble with his daughter years later
there are things where like my daughter
would like this is ableist and
disgusting and okay even at the time
Gili bombed so bad that it like
obliterated Ben's acting career for a
while forcing him to move into directing
and maybe take just a moment to direct
you to that subscribe button before we
move on to a movie that's filled with
the sort of roles Tropic Thunder was
making fun of White Chicks could have
been an opportunity to get back at
Hollywood for movies like Tropic Thunder
instead this movie about two
African-American cops forced to go
undercover as white heiresses quickly
dissolves into some pretty uncomfortable
humor the main characters are constantly
using their disguises to spy on
unsuspecting women plus the movie tends
to lean on some pretty exaggerated
stereotypes about women I'm cellulite
Sally look at my huge donkey and of
course we've got that good old gay Panic
humor here too the guy guys aren't they
wow
you really are disgusting the idea could
have worked if the movie was actually
funny but unfortunately there's just too
many times where they go for the easy
joke it wasn't even well received in
2004. White Chicks was nominated for
five razzies including a worst actress
nomination for the Wayans brothers in
their disguises well they ended up
losing to Halle Berry for that one more
on that later but first let's keep
talking representation it's never easy
to get all the facts straight in a real
person's life but the Blind Side didn't
even seem to try this Academy
award-winning movie started gaining
criticism when someone pointed out that
the plot seemed white Savory and among
those critics was the person the movie
was actually based on former NFL player
Michael Orr he felt that the movie
portrayed him as dumb and especially
took offense to the way that it showed
him as someone who had to be taught the
game of football while watching the
movie or thought no that's not me at all
I've been studying really studying the
game since I was a kid nowadays we
imagine that there would have been more
care taken to get those sorts of details
right on The Blind Side I was 11 12
years old getting up on my own going to
school when somebody else get that
credit yeah it pisses you off but as our
next entry proves the movie industry
wasn't all too sensitive in the 2000s so
this entry tries to leave us with an
uplifting message which is at least
better than our next entry does Shallow
Hal is about learning to see past
physical appearances so you can
appreciate someone for who they are but
that message becomes a little harder to
see when it's hiding behind one
never-ending fat joke Jack Black plays a
man who's been hypnotized to see
everyone for their inner beauty meaning
that he thinks Gwyneth Paltrow's
character is supermodel thin when she's
actually obese she breaks chairs when
she sits down sinks her side of the
canoe and does all sorts of unrealistic
things that are meant for a cheap laugh
Gwyneth Paltrow even had to wear a fat
suit for some of her scenes something
that she's since gone on to regret when
she asked her best friend to guess what
her least favorite performance was he
immediately went with Shallow Hal and
she didn't at all disagree exactly she's
even gone so far as to call the whole
movie a disaster
speaking of stereotypes Van Wilder is a
doozy like calpen plays an Indian
stereotype whose name is
this cringe was so real that Cal even
hung up his agent after she told him the
character's name but she called him back
explaining she couldn't get me in the
door for auditions that weren't written
Brown and the only Brown parts that were
written were written to be fairly
stereotypical Cal hoped that by taking
these roles he'd be opening himself up
to better options in the future an
approach that like seemed to have worked
considering his career nowadays if Cal
was offended by this role imagine what
he would have thought about our next
entry add on to that list the fact that
much of Van Wilder focuses on Ryan
Reynolds character inappropriately
hitting on Tara Reid when she's just
trying to do her job as a journalist
it's a date it's an interview not a date
and there's just no way this movie could
have been made today we aren't
necessarily loving this Guru nowadays
The Love Guru Stars Mike Myers as a
Hindu Guru and so much of the movie is
just one long joke making fun of the
culture whether it be Ben Kingsley and
Brown face playing Guru tug in my Puda
elephant love scenes or the phony Hindu
greetings
there is little about this movie's
cultural representation that would sit
well with audiences today even in 2008
there were people in Myers's home
country of Canada demanding that the
movie shouldn't be released there
without receiving some serious edits
first and one Hindu leader from Nevada
described it as lampooning Hinduism and
Hindus and besides that the movie is
like filled with gross out humor that
was clearly made to be shocking but it
just sort of makes it a slog to sit
through and speaking of movies that are
basically just one long insensitive joke
nowadays we have romantic comedies about
actual gay relationships like love Simon
but in the 2000s we had to make do with
I Now Pronounce You Chuck and Larry as a
result of some unconvincing legal red
tape two straight men are forced to
marry one another and the rest of the
movie is event making awkward gay Panic
jokes she's the husband yeah we heard
you like with Shallow Hal the movie
tries to come around by giving us an
uplifting message in the end but the
concept isn't the movie's only problem
there's also every scene where Rob
Schneider appears playing a Japanese
wedding efficient who's just so cringe
you will need to have a witness we're
gonna Supply one for 100 100 doll hairs
pretty much every moment he's on screen
is a joke at the community's expense and
the movie was bad enough to earn eight
Razzie nominations and there's no doubt
that superhero movies are made different
nowadays even the worst of them try to
stick a little closer to their Source
material than this movie did Catwoman is
about a shy woman who's given cat-like
Powers after being revived by an
Egyptian deity and what does that have
to do with the cat burglar from the
comics and why does she act like an
actual cat now catnip that isn't even to
mention the way that the movie over over
focuses on Halle Berry's body in the
most revealing catsuit ever the
conflict's pretty low stakes for a
superhero movie too hitting Catwoman
against a Makeup Company selling face
cream that rots your skin if you stop
using it yeah it's a pretty bad movie
proving why superhero movies are just
made differently now but oddly enough it
wasn't the only movie from the 2000s
about a shy person who gets a serious
attitude makeover what do you think
happens to you if you're just too nice
well according to Me Myself and Irene
you develop a split personality the
movie's treatment of mental disorders
was just so cringed that even at the
time of its release the National
Alliance on Mental Illness wrote a
letter to 20th Century Fox arguing that
the movie pushed forward the myth that
schizophrenia was a split personality
Jim Carrey was even asked to give a
public service announcement discussing
the difference between schizophrenia and
disassociative identity disorder but he
never did and to make matters worse Jim
Carrey's other personality in the film
has a tendency to say some pretty
offensive things just look at the scene
where he mocks a woman for buying
feminine hygiene products but which of
these movies from the 2000s were you
shocked to see that got made it all and
were there any more examples that you
didn't see on the list we'd love to hear
what you think so don't forget to make
yourself heard down below
foreign